la première étape du tour de france
après la cérémonie de départ à l'endroit
même où les premières équipes s'était
élancé il ya cent ans
place à la compétition la vraie avec une
série de chutes et la victoire de
l'italien alessandro pettachi natale
d'art ensa la chute est spectaculaire
elle aurait pu être dramatique cet après
midi à 500 mètres de la ligne d'arrivée
à mot le peloton connaît sa première
chute collective du tout une quinzaine
de coureurs tombe par terre
créons un étonnant embouteillages
les premiers blessés comme ici jimmy
casper sont immédiatement prise en
charge les moins touchés passe la ligne
un peu comme ils peuvent
une certitude le tour commence mal voilà
je suis toute la journée comme en 1903
le tour s'offre un départ au réveil
matin de montgeon compétitive et
cotillons accompagnent les coureurs
le public est comblé c'est exceptionnel
c'est pour ça que je suis venu la
déplacer que j'ai pas devant la télé
la caravane les couleurs pour le plus
grand plaisir des spectateurs
la première échappée du centenaire et
française beneteau mangin et puis
quinger pause compagnie au peloton
ils comptent jusqu'à huit minutes
d'avancé malheureusement pour eux les
espoirs de victoire s'envole un peu
avant l'arrivée lorsque les équipes de
sprinteurs accélère
il faudrait aussi ça veut faire mémoire
un peloton lancé à 60 à l'heure dans les
15 années km a pas trop d'espoir sur la
ligne de mots l'italien alessandro
petacchi règle au sprint ce qu'il reste
du peloton
c'est sa première victoire sur le tour
de france bradley mcgee lui a toujours
le sourire
son aventure en jaune continue